The joe rogan experience.
Oh yeah.
It's so obviously her Piper's terrified of snakes.
Well,
if he wasn't before,
he pulled a gun on me one time over snake,
man.
Really?
Yeah.
What happened?
I snuck up behind him with a snake and he fucking heard me.
She's Jagan went,
yeah.
He goes,
I know what you're fucking doing.
He don't.
He don't even get his fucking pistol and pull around,
motherfucker.
I'll kill you.
I'm like,
okay.
Ready again.
When I get it.
The guy was shaking,
man.
That's a real thing.
Here's the story.
I'm in the locker room behaving myself,
my Nigga soul,
I believe I was cleaning the wash cloth,
blackboards off and making them nice for everybody and macho walks.
Anyway,
we're really,
it's the story fucking going around.
We're going to get done and do it.
Dude.
Sounds great,
and he's like,
we to take care of a little business Merced
who built this sneak.
Yeah.
Has He been fixture?
Not Fixed.
You mean poisonous?
He goes,
yeah,
that might be the fucking bro.
I'm like,
Randy,
of course he's been fixed.
He goes,
maybe as in maybe Hess,
stranger things have happened in the WWE.
Somebody wants to macho man,
intercontinental Levy,
we champion,
shoot
poisonous snake going fucking rest is history
stage to chimp.
I'm like,
dude,
are you fucking cheek?
I'm just telling you this.
He has to blink you now.
Wow.
I'm like,
what?
He goes it,
but we got to go at it right now.
Me and you.
And he's up in my fucking face with his fist and I'm fuck man.
What the fuck is wrong with you don't bleed no fucking games.
Ah.
So I got to sneak out,
man.
I'm like,
how the fuck?
I'm like any special place you want it to bite me like my deck.
It's like,
where's good?
How about the leg?
I'm like,
fine.
So I got to Cobra out and I pulled my pant leg up,
Shimmin him a little bit and stuck my leg up here and he fucking bet me,
you know,
three,
four seconds.
Let's go.
March was like,
no,
don't book your move.
Don't take no lectures.
Don't take no pills.
Pitcher,
Shit.
Just fucking shit there.
I want to see the boys.
You go through your body
and
finally after about 10 minutes,
she's like,
I'm going to get,
you're going to be okay.
Oh sorry.
Didn't fucking make you happy.
You know,
if I know you want me to die,
he's like no being which night brother,
you fever once this snake,
let's go with me
bringing back may want you looking back up again because I want this idea to
fucking amicus both some fucking big money.
Yeah.
Can you dig it?
Dig It.
All right,
we're out of here.
Wow,
that's it.
All right motherfucker.
You wait.
It was pitch man.
Cause it's one thing to get bit and the heat of a moment.
But to sit there and fucking cold have to hike or fucking pant legs up and let a
fucking snake chew on you to make a motherfucker happy.
Come on,
give me a break.
We're asking a lot.
So if all those people were there,
I wouldn't have felt any effects to sit there.
And I in the locker room cold,
really?
Eh,
no budge pumping other.
So I remember during the match and we do it.
Imagine when it comes down,
time in the ropes,
you get the snake out came this,
make sure he's little unhappiness.
When I turned my back to macho man,
he doesn't see me and I fucking paint brush the hell out of this fucking snake.
I pounded that motherfucker.
Why?
In a second time his fucking mouth full up and brother and he's looking for
anything to fucking bikers,
you know?
And I just went whoa.
And took him to macho man and Boomi latched on and he's true and he's shown my
match.
You're doing a great job.
Well Randy,
you look so believable.
Oh God to him,
you know,
and he's fucking nuts.
What did they do to the snake and move this poison glands and I,
the venom sac.
Yeah.
So there's no venom in its body damaged.
They replaced it with fucking
stuff they use for bullying plants,
man,
you know
silicone,
silicone.
Who are these guys to de Judge also,
because Mike didn't tell you,
but one of the judges on that tribunal who was saying,
Oh,
you're a piece of shit for making fun of a kid after that was found to have
kitty porn.
He was some kind of child molester.
He was judging that he was too shitty to a kid.
There were two people at the Human Rights Commission in Quebec that we're one of
them.
Uh,
what's the precedent that had to resign that he had paid off a 13 year old girl
like 15 years ago to not tell anyone that he had had sex with her.
And then another one,
I think he had had sex with a,
it was a six year old,
like it was fucking crazy.
But these motherfuckers that,
that's what I hated.
These,
these people were telling me,
okay,
you're,
you did a joke onstage and that's all and your intent,
that's what people forget oftentimes in my intent wasn't to hurt this little
kid.
My intent was to make people laugh.
But these guys,
their intent was to put their dick inside of a child that's fucking,
and they judged him and they judged me.
It's fucking crazy.
Well,
hypocrisy knows no bounds.
And I think you know anybody that's doing anything like that,
it's just a sickness that's incomprehensible.
These fucking guys,
man.
So they put you through some shit like you,
you went through this for a long time.
Like my,
my lawyer went when I first met my lawyer,
I told him,
he was like,
look,
they want you to settle.
And he goes,
I could,
um,
get it reduced,
get it reduced.
So like 20 grand.
And I was,
I told him,
I said,
if I do that,
I'm fucking everyone.
Like any comic in Canada is going to be fuck cause I'm going to set this weird
precedent.
So I told him,
I was like,
I'd rather give you 100,000 then give them five.
So then,
but he told me,
he was like,
we can't win the,
the,
cause I didn't go to court.
I went to the human rights tribunal.
I was judged by the human rights tribunal and the Human Rights Commission was
bringing me there.
So it was me versus them judged by them.
So he told me,
you're definitely going to lose to the kangaroo court.
Yeah.
But he said,
yeah.
He said,
uh,
then we'll appeal and the government will probably accept the,
to to listen to the,
the case again.
And then he goes,
then you'll win that.
And,
but so I said yes.
I was like,
look,
I,
I have to do this.
And I'm out.
I,
I loved rocky and there was something weird about,
I was like,
this is like fucking rocky too.
I'm going to be loose and then I'll get out to an LP,
the champ.
So,
but,
so then I was,
something really weird happened to me though,
is I didn't,
I didn't think it did affect me this much because when I was in court and I saw
this kid's family fucking crying,
and I was like,
Holy Fuck,
okay,
these people really took this shit seriously.
And I felt it was weird because my,
my joke,
my intent was to make people laugh.
And this kid,
I fucking nothing against this kid.
I don't,
I don't not like them.
you know,
but then to see that they took this,
this seriously and then the,
how the media was portraying me,
like,
uh,
the,
the in,
I did a series of shows in Edinburgh and there's a newspaper,
Montreal,
the road,
Mike Ward,
Mike Ward is getting rich off of this little boy and I was doing shows in
Edinburgh that no one makes money.
They're like,
I was playing like the 200 seat theater and I was like,
oh,
these fuckers are making me look like I becoming rich because of this little
kid.
He became a target.
Yeah.
And then click bait.
That's how they get people to pay attention.
And I didn't think it did affect me,
but the thing that,
I think the reason why it did affect,
affect me is if all you get is hate,
you can block it out.
It's super easy to block,
hate out.
And I'll error if all you get is love.
That's easy too.
But I was getting hate and love,
so,
so I'd be like,
you know,
I wouldn't let the hate in.
But then someone had shown me love side open up,
and then the hated come in and it was just so fucking weird and F and I was like
googling myself too much.
I'd be like,
oh.
oh,
fuck.
Okay.
There's an article about me in,
in Russia,
and then I Google translate to see that I'm a piece of garbage.
Yeah.